hi rejects I am Greg time John we're
gonna watch a video from gene Jeter at
our patreon page one of our top reward
tiers if you request a video we must do
and put up on the youtubes got a few
coming this month that our podcast
request thank you guys and some are
still reaction and one guy has a lot
lined up for us that's gene
he says for this one which is called
Love Train this year I'm celebrated the
10th anniversary of my web series called
Love Train dat air from 2009 to 2012 at
a hundred million viewers per episode in
there were 35 episodes with some
reaching over 300 million views the web
series explored many things like
sexuality lucid dreams and time travel
but mainly it explored the paranormal
and the New York train system we're
almost at a minute here the first half
were roughly 2 to 5 minutes each it was
only physical acting but then the second
half increase to 15 minutes each where
you heard the actors I wrote three books
based on the characters from these
series oh yeah jeans also l ron Hubbard
the final installment just came out this
February please check out one of the
videos from the web series called La Vie
ok alright here we go and then he wants
us to check out the trailer afterwards
and I said
you ready John I'm so ready I'm always
ready for a gene jeter joint
big bad breath
that's the restroom restroom the change
of the video rest Earth resting thorough
I let you feed me strawberries
you know Sam man let her finish with
drivers like if she want additional dirt
you wanted to eat strawberries but not
by your own hand the [ __ ] eat the
strawberry dumbass this robbery has
transported him to the beach I'm gonna
interpret your [ __ ] this time Jean I
[Music]
would definitely let her feed me
strawberries I'm just saying she is
attractive she is a little more that
might be a trick the x-ray video
using I would do the iMovie sound effect
is suspenseful the rumble sound sorry
for disrupting your head oh all that
[ __ ] what'd she do to him Brad every
time he gets close to the taste of the
sweetness
[Music]
sweet motion oh oh don't trust her man
he's exhausted from that one time each
person so there's a long sprint all
right he's not been fronting to Holly
she gonna eat it not the berries just
the way
[Music]
that's goddamn that's how many times do
you have to do that take you trapped in
like a patent pac-man loop
[Music]
what date is it
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
wish
this [ __ ] right
[Music]
to train
[Music]
so the ghost of Christmas yet to come
[Music]
wolf
you got them finally hard out there for
a pimp man whoa that's what's called
this series is called gene cheaters.com
it's perfect marketing cuz if you go to
gene Jeter comm it's just a video cool
Delilah's strawberry we will talk about
it don't you worry well we will now it's
time to watch The Love Train web series
trailer this is the order in which I
like to do this this is your dream I all
right if I'm like wait you want us to
watch the trailer after yeah that's how
I do every viewing experience because
then it's truly a little expansion
[Music]
the white the Whiteman Whiteman nice
sexy - Oh Dan they're just both happen
to be sexy that's how I wave to stranger
hot chicks hey [ __ ] you that's a man
whoa why she okay slub train is taking
advantage of people yelling no no I know
I don't believe this
it should cornflakes are real - buddy
yo yo yo yes please saying is rap with
this whoa hey whoa
this is not joking not a Love Train I
[Music]
don't
[Music]
maybe you got a permit flexor
[Music]
whoa hey
whoa my pulse is beating with sexual
urges gene is of all the half-naked
ladies Reaper ghost
[Music]
[Music]
Murphy has permission from the subway
stations whoa god I hope so fresh shot
we're just gonna steal this shot in the
subway train with an old-timey gun this
we need the Colt well dude after
watching the episode of it and then
watching the web series trailer I
finally know what this show is about it
all makes sense now it all makes sense
do you guys understand it comment below
you guys can subscribe to the reject
name yeah I think we're done don't
alright job look the Love Train let me
try to hop inside Gene's strange of dis
of a mind hard side genes being I think
the Love Train
is a place that tempts you with some
kind of lustful things seduction but
then it puts you in some type of I don't
want to say purgatory but almost a
Twilight Zone type of deal of limbo a
limbo of sorts where there's torture and
then if you come out of it you're just
not the same person that your brains a
little bit altered and your perception
of things have changed kind of like love
time to like love kind of like in the
way how when you experience love similar
to how people say money doesn't destroy
you it just brings out more of who you
really are
I think love can do that too sometimes
it brings out a darkness in you doesn't
know there's any positive effects of
love in this but I did see are a lot of
paranoia a lot of hot half-naked chicks
some random acts of violence being
stranded I want to know what this love
train is I mean he's had a lot of
episodes some that have gotten a hell of
a lot of views dude we need to get the
DVD boxset and I
think the weirdness of jeans [ __ ] lends
to a really interesting trailer because
his stuff is so bizarre and surreal and
it's in your face and it's just so
quintessentially you like there's no
stuff I watch that's quite like a gene
Jeter joint oh yeah yeah yeah
I appreciate the trainers doing your
thing you know and I like this surreal
strange sci-fi you know train portal
that you've created here maybe that's it
maybe the strawberry is the stand-in for
that first bite of love but then you're
transported into a mind game maybe gene
had an ex-girlfriend named Delilah it
started off great but then it was just
nothing mind game well due dates were
the inspiration episode nineteen though
of that we watched I don't know why you
make a start from the top I mean the
first the first ones like two minutes
the thumbnail people just [ __ ]
macking on each other right here that's
a Love Train that's a Love Train that's
a freaking love Tresor train with some
love I have is standing through the past
minute to a minute and 40 seconds and
they're just making out it's a
two-minute video yeah but the twist is
they didn't really make out they just
made out in their dreams that's kind of
what I'm getting from the visual aid
here see maybe this Love Train is like a
Twilight Zone but set to a train and
maybe some of the episodes are very
sweet and you know it's like oh they
could have had this beautiful romance
their heads are touching but all they're
just asleep the second glass is called
God revelation so and it's 15 minutes I
imagine that's probably when we're gonna
start understanding what's happening
here in the luxury this is like his
version of lost where he illegally shot
a bunch of short films on a subway
station without a permit and hopes they
wouldn't get caught in hopes that people
wouldn't rat to the other attendants I'd
like to think that most of this was shot
in transit two different photo shoots
that's why you have so many appearing is
like okay well now that we're at the
location where we're gonna do this photo
shoot
let's get a little bit of b-roll for the
film before we get back on the train and
make the most out of that time shooting
less I think I think you would be
correct John I think I probably could be
but hey that's maximizing your time and
hey that is the number one thing
arguable you want to do on any shoot
guys you can go to gene Jeter dot-com
you should check out his channel link in
the description box and pin comment he
really is a nice guy the last video we
recovered of his was called white
privilege oh yeah there's a reaction to
his poem
I love the response that he gets on his
own video and the response on our video
because people think he's a white guy
yep you think he's white which we I mean
in our video we read the whole caveat
that it's voice actors but you know the
people people don't feel though know it
that it's written by a not white person
not white guys before like this entitled
like prick
how dare he espoused such ignorance on
the right time at home about why being
white is the best I would not if I was
white these are the most viewed reaction
of ours guards gene Jeter's batteries
marching Jeter reactions this is gonna
be a season of a show in and of itself
is just our gene blue jeans and realize
he's put us on the gene train the that
the the gene rejection this is well this
is what it will be is is is you know our
series of gene Jeter reactions will be
called gene train change right and then
we'll just number each of them gene
train 35 train man welcome to the gene
Train look from here on out you expect
that at the top of every video
welcome to the gene track guys you can
subscribe to the gene strange yeah like
that notification bell we'll catch you
soon
you